Adam is in Atlanta hi Adam welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show hey buddy how are
you doing today
better than I deserve what's up I have
got well he was trying to get some
wisdom oh no I'm self-employed and last
year personally built my wife and little
girls built a new house
and I did it and ended up saving a lot
of money and I paid cash for it as I
went and finished it out and so we've
got a very nice house paid for still
have some the land that its own money on
that that's not paid for but I did pay
for the house has I built it so I didn't
have a mortgage on that getting back to
the self-employed park I have a business
yeah I guess a vendor basically called
an account due because of we had a
little discrepancy and long story short
they wanted the money in four weeks and
there's no whales possible so we're
going just started up a lawsuit on it
and I'm trying to figure out would it be
better for me to pull out money on my
house and pay them or set up the payment
terms with them directly rather than the
reason I asked is I'm trying to else not
back what's the balance with the vendor
it's about a hundred grand okay and what
does your business revenue top line in
the year we'll probably do seven eight
hundred thousand this year so why were
they not paid
well it wasn't not paid we did how about
you have you haven't been paying them
off why why are you why you were not two
hundred thousand dollar balance with
them well a lot of that was marketing
through an agency with them as well so a
big chunk of that as they build us
monthly for the large chunk of the ad
revenues and why not pay them well we
yes and no it was it's over
four year period that balance is so yes
I've got a complete fault for the
balance but we did it wasn't they
weren't getting paid it no I'm not
talking about morally I'm gonna tell my
pissed them off I'm talking something
I'm mathematically you you know it was
just sloppy to let this get to this
level right that's all I'm saying
cuz you're makin a you were making
enough to clear the thing and you just
you know you were holding back and
weren't clearing it so now you got now
you gotta clear it in a pong phone
manner
well parsley probably some of that had
to go with me paying for my house as
well so and not I kind of just
misappropriating funds well and that's a
problem that's probably overstating it
I'm it's not misappropriating funds you
were just borrowing from Peter to pay
Paul so I got you okay what's in that
profit what's your household income
taxable a year I'll probably do around
200 this year okay so how quick can you
pay a hundred if you just cashflow it I
would say realistically with all my
other bills probably a year and a half
now they're not going for that yeah we
haven't gotten to the terms yet that
it's kind of just started yeah so we're
just beginning that you know I don't
think they're gonna go for that
yeah not what you're sitting there with
assets I mean I'm hoping some sort of
settlement out of it okay yeah I'm
thinking a year yeah if you can pay them
in a year in cash flow it and they'll go
for that then I would do that and not
mess up your house how much do you owe
on the land it's in two different
sections but all together right about
200 grand and I'm sayin what is what is
the house and all the land worth the
house is probably worth about 400 grand
and the land is probably right on value
maybe two it's pretty close to what I
owe ya you have six hundred thousand
dollars worth of property that you owe
$200,000 yes that's
what you're telling me okay what's down
in our house then you can put the dirt
under it for another two hundred exactly
all right and so you yeah I'm gonna try
to put them on a one-year payout and I'm
going to cut your lifestyle down and
we're gonna roll money out of that
business towards that where it should
have been going which is getting this
vendor cleared up if you can pull that
off hi
you know I don't think they're going to
go for much more than a year I wouldn't
if I were on the other side this table
I'd force your hand and make you go get
a mortgage
I'm not waiting a year on you maybe to
pay me unsecured if I'm on the other
side of this so I don't know it depends
on how lightweight they are in their in
their negotiations with you but if you
can pay them over a year I would if
they're trying to cram it down where you
know it's going to be two months you
don't have an option you have to go take
out a mortgage at that point and that's
probably going to involve rolling the
land into a house mortgage and it'll all
be one mortgage and so you're gonna end
up with a $300,000 mortgage on six
hundred thousand dollars for the
property which is not the end of the
world but learning your lesson from it
that you have to cash flow vendors you
know account that runs 31 days is
overdue you cashflow your vendors and if
you don't have your business model set
up to order you it can anticipate your
vendor expenses to clear them every 30
days like this then you got a business
model that's that's broken and you got
to watch that and tighten up on it and
so because you're did what a very
typical small business mistake here and
you can get yourself in a real bind
doing that the good news is you've got
assets and income to address at this
time so you got to figure it out from
there that this doesn't happen again
so hey good question Matt I appreciate
you appreciate you calling in and I hope
that helps you